l'île noire illustre albums d'hergé
pareil pour la première fois en
feuilleton hebdomadaire dans le magazine
belge le petit vingtième
il y a de cela près de 60 ans il est
publié ultérieurement en volume et en
couleurs en 1943 puis moderniser en 1965
les éditions casterman éditeurs des
premiers jours et qu'il est demeuré
depuis remet en vente pour les amateurs
l'édition 2009 143 évidemment un peu
désuète mais pleine de charme
en dépit de son goût proverbiale du
détail rg avaient commis quelques
erreurs dans sa transcription de la
réalité britannique qu'il devait
corriger par la suite mais cependant
l'édition 2009 143 demeure un ouvrage
est patent plein de vieilles locomotives
et de guimbarde d'un autre âge compte à
mulhouse enivrant ou johnnie walker
cela demeure un très bon souvenir pour
tous les invraisemblances chez hergé
comme chez hitchcock n'ont jamais nui à
l'agrément ici l'île en question recèle
dans ses anfractuosités les rotatives
des faux monnayeurs et un avion prêt à
décoller on a vu beaucoup mieux dans
james bond qui n'atteint jamais à la
poésie de hergé
et puis l'art du récit du cadrage chez
ce dernier est tout simplement sans égal